احنا وقفوا تساريح هنا ورحنا على المعبر
عشان نروح على الضفه مسكونا من المعبر
وحملنا البصات ودونا على عوفه وبعديه
حطونا في كمات زي خم الدجاج قعدوا زي
الدجاج تربيط تفتيش تربيط تفتيش فيش
كهرباء ضرب اهانه ذل كل شيء تتوقعوه شفناه
احنا نقول لهم ننا عمال نقول لك ننا
عارفين ان انتم عمال بس اهاليكم اللي
عملوا فيكم هيك غزه اللي عملت فيكم هيك مش
احنا احنا ما بنعرفش شي عن اهالينا ولا
بنعرف اي حد الاتصال ما فيش 25 يوم ما فيش
اتصال اخذوا كل شي منا ولا خلوا معان حاجه
احنا كنا بنشتغل يعني في شغل كل الناس
بتشتغل في شغلها شايف كيف بعدين صار
الحوادث الحادث اللي صار هذا في ناس روحت
وناس ظلت احنا من الناس اللي ظلينا واجت
الشرطه واعتقلت هنا قعدنا شهر واحنا
[موسيقى]
معتقلين